Moana you've got some serious guts the
ocean sent you on a massive journey and
you were brave enough to accept to the
mission but you didn't even know how to
sell a boat so your chances of making it
were pretty slim luckily you had your
grandma Tala and the ocean spirits
guiding you every step of the way not
only did you beat the odds but you even
showed a certain demigod how it's done
did you ever wonder why the ocean chose
Moana it was a dream no we've got all
the answers
keep watching to the end to discover the
decision mo Ana's parents made when she
was born that made her destiny to be the
chosen one the first time we see this
Disney Princess she's listening to her
grandma telling this hell about to
feeding and she's totally spellbound
unlike the other little kids around her
who fainted and cried after hearing the
scary story so it makes sense that out
of all the kids on mallanna's Islands
the ocean singled her out but there's
more to it than that
Moana is the daughter of the village
chief and gets to be the next in charge
that means she's got plenty of influence
over her people as the leader she can
tell them what to do but she can also
lead by example by setting out across
the ocean she proved to her people that
it was safe to go beyond the reef this
was something her father failed at it's
pretty clear why the ocean couldn't
choose chief Dewey after losing his
friend in the water he became totally
afraid of the Seas powerful force and
forbade his people to journey beyond the
reef however his mother grandma Tala
loved ocean exploration
just like her granddaughter Moana
however the ocean couldn't choose
grandma Tala to restore the heart of
de-feet II that's because the ocean
needed someone young and fit and someone
who would have power Moana always loved
the ocean even though her father tried
to keep her away why did she have that
pool towards it
because it was in her DNA after all her
ancestors were South Pacific navigators
they were master voyagers traveling
across the open water to find new
islands so the ocean could trust that
Moana would know
to sail across it because that was a
skill that was in her bones the ocean
needed to wait a little while before
explicitly choosing Moana however sure
she had the power from the day she was
born
she had the ancestry and she showed a
love of the water but she also needed to
prove her character and she did that as
a toddler and one of the cutest scenes
in the movie Moana saves a little ocean
creature she showed great empathy to a
baby turtle instead of picking up the
pretty shell she wanted but wanna help
the turtle return to the ocean under the
shade of a leaf she fought off the birds
attacking it straight after that the
ocean opened up to her
it delivered the heart of tooth Beauty
to her and stuck around to play with her
to the most compelling reason for the
ocean to choose Moana happened even
before she was a toddler though it was
decided on the day of her birth stay
tuned to find out exactly what that is
towards the end of the movie we discover
Maui's opinion on why the ocean chose
Moana he says the ocean loved it when he
pulled up new islands because mallanna's
ancestors would then sail to see and
discover them and Maui said why were the
ocean I think I'd be looking for
curly-haired non princess to start that
again
soon after we discover mallanna's
opinion on why the ocean picked her when
Moana speaks with her grandma spirit she
sings about how the sea calls her the
song is literally called aya Moana song
of the ancestors and she finishes with
the line I am Awana that might just
sound like she finally knows who she is
but there's much more to it than that
her destiny was in her name the name
Moana means ocean wide expanse of water
and deep sea in Maori and Hawaiian as
well as in other Polynesian languages so
when she sings
I am Moana she is also saying I am the
ocean with a link like that how could
the ocean choose anyone other than her
we know that Chiefs tui was scared of
the deep sea and wanted to protect his
people from it but by naming his
daughter Moana he was cementing her fate
do you think he realized that at the
time or was it a subconscious decision
or a total fluke whatever the reasoning
behind mallanna's name it can't he
denied that it was her destiny to
restore the heart of 2pt
I like the empathy she showed to the
turtle she shows compassion to the
villain tika as well though Anna
identifies with tika she heals her pain
restoring her back to two feet II
[Music]
the movie screenwriter Jarrod Bush spoke
at BuzzFeed about Moana searched to
discover why the ocean chose her he
reveals that Moana was able to discover
that tika is to fede
because Moana auntie fede have gone
through a similar thing they're both in
search of their true identity as we've
seen from all these reasons Moana was
the oceans perfect choice which reason
do you think is most important let us
know in the comments make sure to
subscribe to the things for more videos
like this one and don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching catch you next time
[Music]